when you think of what you eat from a
diet standpoint what do you follow a
species of diet so what is the main
things the main thing is actually what
you said like intermittent fasting so i
haven't eaten anything today so i'm
doing 18 hours with zero calorie intake
just water um and black coffee but no no
calorie intake yeah which is by the way
you any form of fasting is great that's
just the fasting which works for me in
sort of my daily rhythm like other
people do five-day fasting and then eat
normally so i do like 16 to 18 hours no
calorie intake why uh you said it it's
counterintuitive but like your body goes
into like a laundry mode you could say
that way like sort of it's flushing out
senescent cells it's really rejuvenating
and it starts round about hour 14 that
you go into that sort of state so so the
longer actually you can be if you could
be sometimes i make a full day yeah
without food or without anything that is
actually ideal um i tried to not eat a
lot of carbs um
maybe the healthy ones lentils whatever
but not the bad ones carbs a pasta blah
blah
i actually take performance that is i
think sort of from the medical side the
most we know potent using metformin
metformin yeah which is actually a
diabetes drug but which seems to mimic
fasting and then there is a a newer
version which actually is interesting
because um i always have in psychedelics
with some people that discussion about
patterns like is it allowed to patent
psychedelic substances because it's
god's
given things and i i think patterns are
inherently important for drug
development which we unfortunately see
with metformin because metformin is a
diabetes drug which is out of pattern
it's super cheap so there are great
studies but not fda studies so more like
looking at people who take metformin how
they
how they age whatever which suggests
that metformin is incredibly healthy but
no pharma company is putting the money
up to prove it in an fda-like framework
because they can't make money with it so
it would be great if metformin is in
patent again because people would then
hopefully prove it like somebody did it
novo nordisk has a drug called ozempeg
which is also a diabetes drug so it
shows by the way that it seems to be
that so when you take metformin what
does it do
so it's kind of
in a non-medical way it's mimicking
fasting yeah it's controlling your
insulin spike and that whole world of
taking food especially sugar or
sugar-like foods yeah which makes your
insulin spike whatever that seems to
over the course of our life be one of
the drivers for inflammation
cardiovascular diseases whatever so with
four main sort of in a more complex way
than i can describe it now but it's sort
of
sort of bringing that back bringing that
out and the same is just empic but what
i was saying is like because it's in
patent they've proven it so osempic now
has been fda approved not just for
diabetes but for weight loss yeah and
for
prevention of cardiovascular diseases
okay do you take anything else like nad
or yes everything i take 50 pills a day
all right so metformin slides there so
but it's forming what are the essentials
metformin i take nld plus what does
nadplus do for folks i just pulled up
very quickly uh this is a paper in
science uh that basically talks about
nad plus an aging metabolism and neuro
degeneration right and basically the
whole idea is uh a lot of aging comes
down to
metabolism the
destruction of your cells the faster
deterioration of them etc and so each
one of these things i'm assuming that
you're taking has some impact some of
them are directly some of them are
indirectly whatever insulin it all plays
into this complex system that is the
human body but that's essentially what
you're trying to get at is to slow down
the deterioration of the cells or even
potentially build building them back up
and kind of the
the idea that you can reverse your
biological age versus your chronological
age is you know appears to be possible
uh according to some of these guys yeah
there's this great study you can do it
with human growth hormones like uh there
was these i think it was stanford study
if 70 old men take human growth hormones
metformin and dhea
and then the question is by the way uh
we're coming to an interesting point
what is actually how do we measure
sort of um uh age like sort of not your
age in birth years but in like uh like
how you appear or how you feel yeah
which we don't have yet and stanford was
the first one i think it was stanford
who developed like a scale
we're like okay if we give
these whatever 20 men like human growth
hormones metformin and dha how can we
measure if they really rejuvenate
and they came up with a number of
biomarkers whatever which is by the way
the
one of the tasks we have to do
in cambrian uh james just started a a
big sort of
think tank where we sort of align all
it's called longevity
biotech companies because at the moment
if you go to the fda and say hey i found
the wonderpill yeah
which makes us live 10 years longer it's
really hard to get
an approval or actually even the study
approved because you're not solving for
a real problem because aging and dying
is not classified as a disease so what
all these aging companies do at the
moment and this is what cambrian for
example and they have another one in
europe rejuveron these are my two
aging plays what they're doing
is like you have to find drugs which
have
an imminent immediate effect on a
certain disease yeah
and then you can approve it for that
disease but you have a second layer
effect that you know okay once i have
approved it for this single disease
everybody will take it because it's so
beneficial yeah i'll give you one
example we're working on one drug um
actually pretty advanced yeah so the
shortening of the telomeres yeah is one
other in these nine hallmarks of aging
have you guys just real quick have you
guys read the telomere effect no i
should read it basically for those uh in
the most elementary example uh you know
your shoelace you know it has on the end
of the shoelace the plastic caps
basically every single one of your dna
strands has these like essentially caps
to them and as they get shorter the
shorter your telomeres get basically the
more aging you have the shorter your
lifespan will be and so there's a bunch
of things that you can do like in
immense stress bad eating whatever to
accelerate the shortening of the caps
but also the belief is that maybe you
can slow down the shortening or
potentially could you reverse it because
you actually extend back the cap so that
you're essentially reversing uh kind of
the the negative effect on television
yeah and permanently it's amazing like
perfectly explained and there's i don't
just know about bitcoin but i just like
thinking about this
fascinating um so and you have a
childhood disease and everybody of us
has seen that because once in a while
the media is like oh look at this child
it's like looks like an eight-year-old
but it's 19. like so there is a disease
where the telomeres shrink and shorten
in rapid speed and then unfortunately
children who have this disease look with
15 like an 80 year old which is showing
that i saw so we have a drug
in phase one but so a little bit
advanced but not
years away but like sort of in the
middle of drug development yeah which we
think has the potential to cure their
childhood disease so that is a real
disease i can go to the fda it's
actually even yeah an orphan disease so
i can get very quick approval because
these children are dying when they are
20. yeah but obviously if i get a drug
approved which stops shortening of the
telomeres uh for these children
very clear
use case then i would take it as well if
it stops the shortening of my telomeres
yeah so and this is at the moment how
all
longevity companies do these work around
so they find a molecule or a compound
and they have an assumption but they
always have to prove it in a concrete
disease
and i hope and this would be lobbying
for that in some years the sooner the
better uh especially the fda as the sort
of number one regulator in the world is
saying well let's define
biomarkers which define aging
and if you can change these biomarkers
positively so if you sort of can slow
down and provenly slow down aging we do
approve that we could because we agree
with you and this is what it is aging is
a disease yeah and we have to sort of
solve it